[Music]
and scare tactics news submitted by yeah
I'm back a school district threatened
hundreds of parents with losing custody
of their kids over lunch jets oh my god
I heard about this and I feel like so
[ __ ] up
yeah because I also heard that there was
a social-media influencer like with a
lot of money and there was like a
politician and somebody else would try
to pay the student debt off but the
school was like no the parent has to pay
for it
why and apparently like people are
saying like it's not really about the
money it's that you're trying to hit
lower-income communities and trying to
get the kids into like away from the
parents you know [ __ ] up yeah there
was one quote saying like I feel like
there were just one sentence away from
saying we're gonna lock your children
children in cages and send them to
Mexico
well so what okay so this school in
Pennsylvania there's a lot of Mexicans
there I don't know but they no no oh
sorry that's Arizona New Mexico
California
yeah Latin Pennsylvania would be venison
I'm evil because I knew that like in New
York there's a big Mexican population
there - doesn't everything population I
think I think you buddy quads and like
no cuz you know why I just watched this
gang documentary and it was like yeah
there was like Sudan you know so Daniels
there and I was like wow well you could
be from anywhere I'm loosening a few oh
really I think so I mean I don't know
but it's the x13 I think if you like hit
them up and you're like what's that can
I join yeah there'd be like you want to
pay taxes yeah alright come on mister
Tina's Salvadoran right but they're not
a sureno though they're just it's it's
okay so like what I real I thought so
too because of the 13 and then it's just
it means something else that just
coincidentally they use 13 but they're
not a part of the Mexican Mafia yeah
yeah that's what I thought too
maybe it's cuz 13s is scary number four
love you because it's like eBay and
actually yeah it's like you're harder
because I remember in high school I
thought it was so [ __ ] chola which I
was not and I remember having like my my
screen name to be my nickname which is
to keep that and then with the [ __ ] X
13 a day or two
did I do that keep that three but what
happened in Pittsylvania you started and
left me hanging
you know Pennsylvania's one there's
thirteen colonies that's right
thirteen home of the Liberty Bell yeah
and that's where they had the Salem no
that's Massachusetts okay sorry so in
Pennsylvania and I sent out hundreds of
letters telling parents who had lunch
that - hey they had to either pay or
their children would go into foster care
Wow that's [ __ ] bastard care and so
they were saying so the letter said that
parents had been sent multiple letters
home with their child and I quote your
child has been sent to school every day
without money and without a breakfast
and/or lunch oh that's why if you are
taken to dependency courts the results
may be your child being removed from
your home and placed in foster care I
get it they don't think that the parents
are even feeding them at home that's why
well that yeah so that's that that's
what they were saying so this was
definitely just mainly a scare tactic
because they really have no basis to
actually follow through with this oh and
even like the local where the foster
care like the social services office
they even got piss where they were like
[ __ ] like we can't take kids away just
because of this there's no law yeah yeah
yeah they're just it was all just a
scared who was the idiot that made this
up the words of thing no it was the PTA
president look I gotta find it trooper
intended Skinner it was not the suit
janitor president work the Key Club
Treasurer okay it was the director of
federal programs for the school district
he's a man who wrote the letter his
name's Joseph moose and so he's saying
that the letter is the genius that did
it all the letter was a last resort and
that the district is owed more than 22
thousand dollars by roughly 1,000
students and for accounts show that they
owe more than four hundred and fifty
dollars each that's [ __ ] sad cuz
gangster he's like hey we got on a debt
if you don't pay right to start taking
kids we're selling them on the black
market for the
yeah because the the school board they
are pissed they're like what the [ __ ]
like how do you tell our families this
you can't threaten the family so like
the the actual school board is not
behind this it's just this one guy
that's acting upon it so did he get in
trouble I hope so [ __ ] dude good
question I don't know cuz they couldn't
enforce it so yeah well I mean think
about it like imagine you have a kid
you're low-income you don't have like
you're barely working and then they tell
you we're gonna take your kid away if
you don't feed it like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm trying you know a lot of
people send their kids to school to eat
there you know like I was what I forgot
what it was but like I used to get free
lunches like you were typing your number
you know and like if we didn't have that
program like I woulda no way that's cool
like my mom didn't give me money she
couldn't afford it you know
so that's a good place for tax dollars
yeah I love that we had a free lunch
falling down we had summer school and
then I found out later that the reason
why we started having summer school and
like an out like that program was so
kids during the summer can eat meals Wow
yeah cuz I was so happy cuz I was like
we get summer school I live like a block
away from school and then so we would go
and it wasn't like school at all it's
just like they're open you could get
lunch
you could play freaking handball and
then you get classes and you do
different projects that was summer
school I was always afraid of getting
summer school that was my elementary
school that was some that yeah cuz they
didn't do it
and then they started doing it and every
I was like three food hell yeah and
everyone that anyone that came like you
just get a free lunch yeah so I thought
that was awesome good time that I did I
did have to do summer school in middle
school I would remember being so happy
that I was like [ __ ] yeah we get lunch
yeah yeah and it was actually better
than regular school lunch
you think so I think so cuz it was I
think it was like it wasn't the same
menu it wasn't the same stuff yeah it
was like Subway kind of sandwiches that
came in like plastic bags you're right
yeah it's differ
summer school food yeah I'm Kara member
I remember my school lunches that [ __ ]
was good everything bad Little Caesars
pizzas you had a little Caesars at
school so you could get like a little
personal one for like five bucks right
personal Little Caesars five dollars
five bucks tops yeah we had some we had
some way of Pizza Taco Bell Taco Bell I
was considered like well the [ __ ]
apex right if you could if you could get
the five dollar pizza like you were
having a great day you were rich you
were bought have you got the Oh like the
we call them like the welfare tickets
like the yellow or the blue ones there
was a there was a separate lunch but if
you paid money you can get pizza
personal pizza from Pizza Hut or like
Subway where did you grow up like no I
mean like it's it's like American
schools like nah yeah but it's fake
stuff though it's not even real Pizza
Hut and Downey they had it pink oh girl
not down it is but Donnie's like rich
Mexicans exactly [ __ ] Taster's Choice
over the pizza school it was really good
you know Berlin yeah if you remember and
then they had like barely no cheese on
it but it was bond like it was on my set
but full of jeans I mean like a little
bit of cheese so that's the one I had
but my favorite thing was the spicy
chicken sandwiches oh those were bomb
did you guys never have those were bomb
those were bomb at my school yeah for
sure
I remember one time in elementary school
because my elementary school lunch was
bad special and then we didn't have a
dime at home like we could I don't know
I just remember yet my mom actually sent
me home with the vs like the Bissell's
oh and then I gave it to the lady she
was like the [ __ ] is this
what's your white yeah all right I don't
remember but I just remember her
questioning and I was like ten cents
take it might take it's ten pesos yeah
dude I can never be at lunch later I'd
be like [ __ ] just go go no because
they're saying and they're like there's
been a lot of stories recently where
there would be a lunch lady that let a
student take food without paying
and then she ended up telling CNN that
she means that student would pay the $8
tab and then this other one attempted $1
this other high school attempted to
prevent students from attending the
graduation ceremony if they didn't pay
their lunch that sorry thank you do you
remember lunch being like fitness and
yeah like 35 cents or 50 cents or
something what it was it was like a
dollar at my time dollar fish I think
ours was look at all the 25 yeah let me
get a ticket at the dog 25 I would just
punch in my number cuz my I remember my
parents gave me like quarters and that
was my lunch money and I would like oh
yeah now my brother asked for five
dollars I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
buying there the [ __ ] my lunch was like
point three bucks hang in elementary
school right yeah or you got the blue or
blue for breakfast and yellow for lunch
remember those aren't they had the
collar did date on the team it was a
pink ticket and then you buy the booklet
before the semester started and then
each one was like a dollar 25 every bad
cousin went to schools that have the
ticket system and we did it and I was
always jealous on the day you have
tickets it's like money figured yeah
yeah sometimes I feel really bad for
some kids I didn't have lunch in like
that's right in Virginia man there was
this whatever this spaghetti was they
served in cafeteria ice I swear I can
smell it to this day it was so [ __ ]
good to me like as a kid and I'll never
be able to recreate that experience
obviously because I'm sure with [ __ ]
food but for me I was like this is
incredible you should go back to your
elementary and Jessie I know I should
have you ever had a top have you ever
ever have you ever had a taco boat in
California though because I feel like
that's all LAUSD but it's like a taco
shell and it's just cheese with ground
beef on top yeah yeah oh thing I had
we've talked about this before too a lot
for elementary school is the taco pocket
and it wasn't a hard shell it was like a
I thought was like a chimichanga type of
thing but it wasn't and it was only in
elementary school and I remember going
to middle school like [ __ ] we don't have
a taco bar anymore
man I miss all that [ __ ] dude the
cardboard like drinks the oil it's not
anymore there's
it's the plastics getting that little
smudge square brownie things [ __ ]
good man softest [ __ ] cardboard it's
forever since of when I was in school
you don't have to like bend it back and
forth three times open you don't
remember this sack it was like a sign
never have I never have a second oh yeah
morning well I remember because I was
with the sack of mill with the pouch
yeah yeah I had those guys yeah we had
both I mean well I'm older but I still
had the oh maybe it just depends on
school district well cuz yeah and
Virginia had the I had the pouch and
then when I moved to Cali we had the
cardboard yeah cuz for reals elementary
school was a pouch and then a middle
school in high school was the cardboard
I love the patches cuz during like
school fights and shipping dude
nothing's like more than getting a Capri
Sun goes always at first but Capri Sun
will for the rich kids man we talking
about cuz we're expensive I never got
Capri Suns and let's Capri Suns were for
rich kids do those two my mom would
always get off-brand [ __ ] all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]